would you say for a theoretical  cosmologist what should he or she know  at a minimum about experiments in  general it's really important to to be  able to you know converse with theorists  I know like the most important  experiments are is I also think it's  very important to talk to  experimentalists such as it's important  for experimentalists to talk to  theorists I think it's really important  to know your experimentalists there are  different experiments let's go about the  experiments differently they have  different interests just as theorists  have different strengths and weaknesses  so beyond being able to read the paper I  think the the minimum is also that you  know at least a bunch of leading  experimentalists personally